so we've been talking about the
emergence of jacksonian democracy in the
first half of the 19th century in the
United States and we've been talking
about how in this time period the vote
was slowly extended to all white male
citizens so that by the end of this
period there were no more property
requirements in the United States and
any white male citizen could vote now
those property requirements had allowed
three people of color and women to vote
in some states and when voting became
associated with white and male citizens
those little loopholes ended up getting
closed but this expansion of voting
rights to all white male citizens really
represents a shift in how the average
American thought about who deserve to
have a voice in the political process of
the United States they stopped placing
so much value on the sort of
aristocratic Republican citizenship of
the early days of the United States
where someone like George Washington
would never run for office he would
stand for office you wouldn't promote
yourself that would be vulgar instead
you would have men of well-known
character promote you but by the 1820s
very few Americans believed in the idea
that there could be such a thing as too
much democracy that you would have to
avoid the mob rule instead they wanted
the mob rule they wanted a great
expansion of democracy and that was to
them the real character of the United
States now I should also mention that
this expansion of democracy was part of
a larger international expansion of
democracy a similar laws that eliminated
property restrictions on voting were
also being passed in England and France
at this time period so there's kind of
an international wave to broaden the
franchise but the extension of voting in
Europe is nothing like the extension of
voting in the United States there are
nearly twice as many eligible voters in
the United States in 1830s as there are
in Britain with a population that's half
the size so while European nations
taking small steps toward expanding the
franchise the United States is taking
huge steps in this time period so the
first election where we start to see the
influence of this new wave of voters is
in the election of 1824 and may give us
a little bit more space to talk about
this so the election of 1824 was a
contest between John Quincy Adams son of
American founder John Adams Andrew
Jackson famous war hero from the war of
1812 the victor of the Battle of New
Orleans and Henry Clay it will become
known as the great compromiser for
having pretty much spent his entire
political career either running for
president or putting together some kind
of compromise
now John Quincy Adams I think kind of
epitomized the older school of American
democracy
he was reticent to campaign on his own
behalf he was very interested in
academics and internal improvements he
didn't really see himself as being part
of a particular political party in fact
all three of these men were actually
running as Republicans because in the
era of good feelings there's only the
Republican Party so you can see how
confusing this might have been as a
voter to have three different candidates
from the same party and they're supposed
to be different than each other so in
this election Andrew Jackson wins the
popular vote and John Quincy Adams wins
the electoral vote and Henry Clay wins
neither now in a situation like this who
got to be President was decided by the
House of Representatives well guess who
was Speaker of the House Henry Clay so
he's out of the running himself but he
is in a position to make quite an impact
on who wins the presidency
well John Quincy Adams at Henry Clay
didn't have a whole lot in common but
they sure both hated Andrew Jackson so
and Adams meat and Henry Clay says yeah
John Q I'll see if I can get the house
to vote for you and that's what happens
so the house elects John Quincy Adams
president and then just a couple days
later John Quincy Adams says that Henry
Clay will get to be his Secretary of
State which was quite a plum of a
political position and Andrew Jackson
and his supporters go ballistic they say
that this was a corrupt bargain behind
closed doors in which John Quincy Adams
bribed Henry Clay to give him the
presidency in exchange for this
political position now there's no
evidence that this actual corrupt
bargain really happened but even if it
did it was totally in line with the
earlier playbook of American democracy
and you scratch my back I'll scratch
yours kind of situation where the better
sort of men the higher men of character
made a deal between themselves of who
would lead this nation and the outrage
over this possible collusion between
Adams and Clay really signaled that the
old days of a couple of people making
decisions about American politics were
over that this kind of deal between
statesmen was now seen as undemocratic
or crooked or something that was done
behind closed doors and that was against
the American character and Andrew
Jackson is really going to ride his wave
of popular discontent over someone
winning the popular vote but losing the
electoral vote do too in his mind a
corrupt bargain right into the
presidency in the election of 1828 and
we'll get to that in the next video